♪ ♪ ♪
- Fidel Castro a fait son entrée
triomphale à La Ha i i il y a
un peu plus d'un an, lorsqu'une
force anticastriste tente
un débarquement dans la baie
des Cochons, au sud de l'île.
- La tentative d'invasion
se transforme en désastre.
Sur la côte, dans les marais.
des cadavres d'envahisseurs.
- É e e embarrassant pour John
Kennedy, qui vient d'assumer
la présidence américaine.
Convaincu que les Américains
veulent encore prendre l'île
par la force et qu'ils veulent
l'assassiner, Fidel Castro
se tournent vers lononon
soviétique. Cuba bascule
dans le camp communiste.KARINEÉt
prof. Université de Sherbrooke
- Alors, Cuba a sollicité l'aide
de l'URSS évidemment et l'URSS a
décidé d'installer du matériel
militaire sur l'île de Cuba,
à la fois pour protéger l'île
et évidemment, en même temps,
pour mettre un pied si on veut
en terre américaine,
dans le sens continental
du terme. Donc en octobre 62,
il y a des missiles qui sont
installés à Cuba et la CIA
prend des photos et conclut
qu'effectivement, il y a
une menace réelle à ce moment-là
pour les États-Unis.
- Les Soviétiques ont mis
le paquet : 45 ogives nucléaires
visent la Floride à moins de
150 km des côtes. 42 000 soldats
soviétiques sont déployés sur
l'île avec soutien de régiment
d'infanterie de 41 Migs,
quatre vaisseaux de guerre
et 11 sous-marins.
- Alors c'est la consternation
et évidemment, il y  d d des
réactions fort différentes au
sein de l'administration Kennedy
à ce moment-là sur la suite
des choses : qt-t-t-ce qu'on
fait? Comment on réagit?
On ne peut pas les laisser là.
- La flotte et l'aviation
américaine sont en état
d'alerAyAyAyant exigé
de La Havane le démantèlement
des bases de fusée, le président
Kennedy décide d'établir
une quarantaine autour de Cuba.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il y a des faucons dans le
camp acacacain, des militaires
voudraient bombarder les
missiles soviétiques, envahir
l'île. Pendant 13 jours,
la menace nucléaire pèse
sur toute l'Amérique du Nord.
Fidel Castro et Che Guevara
sont prêts au sacrifice ultime.
- Tout à fait et Fidel Castro
en particulier a fait beaucoup
de lobbying, si on peut dire,
auprès de Khrouchtchev pour
qu'il utill'l'l'arme nucléaire
contre les Américains,
parce qu'il disait : ils sont
une menace constante pour nous,
ils l'ont prouvé dans le passé.
-  K K Kennedy, son frère
Robert, les diplomates,
préfèrent la négociation secrète
avec Nikita Khrouchtchev.
- C'est un bluff énorme, hein?
C'est une une grande partie
de poker?
- Ah oui, absolument,
c'est vraiment, là, un coup
de dés que Kennedy a décidé de
faire parce qu'il était persuadé
que quoi que ce soit d'autre
mènerait à la catastrophe
nucléaire. Alors c'est tout
à fait un pari qui aurait pu
être perdu. Mais heureusement,
Khrouchtchev aussi visiblement
avait cette volonté d'éviter
l'escalade.
- Mais alors que Castro est prêt
à vaincre ou à périr, le danger
mortel que court le monde pousse
le président Kennedy et Monsieur
Khrouchtchev à s'entendre
directement. Les bases de fusée
seront démantelées. Monsieur
Mikoïan fait part à Fidel Castro
de la décision du Kremlin
et obtient son accord,
non sans peine.
♪ ♪ ♪
Fidel Castro en gardera
une grande amertume. En échange,
les États-Unis ont accepté
de retirer leurs missiles
nucléaires braqués vers Moscou
en Turquie. Mais l'Accord
restera secret, ce qui donnera
l'impression que le vainqueur,
c'est Kennedy et Khrouchtchev
est le perdant. Mais le monde
est sauvé.
- Les deux superpuissances ont
compris qu'il valait mieux
communiquer, qu'il valait mieux
négocier, qu'il valait mieux
trouver des terrains d'enten
Donc cette détente-là va durer
jusqu'en 1979, jusqu'à
l'invasion de l'Afghanistan
par les Soviétiques.
- Au tournrnrnier moment,
un avion espion américain est
abattu au-dessus de Cuba.
À nouveau, le monde retient
son souffle, mais la raison
auauaut et l'Accord tien